tom would you could could you ever date
a woman that let's say
you know she your wife was in the
picture yeah yeah she ever dated us
yeah and yeah you ever did a woman that
says this listen i know you're on the
road on the weekends
but um you know i don't want you
performing monday tuesday and wednesday
nights because that's those are our
nights
no no of course not of course not that's
what i'm saying
if you were if i were single now that
the person
is whoever i'm dating is stepping into
this universe
and like it's not the other way because
i've had girls say that
no oh yeah i've had girls go you know
you perform so much at night
i get monday and tuesdays no and i'm
like oh all right
that's what then you're at the [ __ ]
lemley watching some [ __ ] movies
holding hands when all your buddies are
having fun oh there's no no
no and also like let's be real here like
i'm hooking you the [ __ ]
up with this lifestyle all right
let's let's [ __ ] cut the [ __ ] yeah
right
what do you work at [ __ ] michael's
arts and crafts you're telling me
what i'm doing [ __ ] tuesday night
yeah get out of here yeah all right
how you felt you felt like you were
hooking me up
well don't pause that long well can i
say something yeah
because i know that he was going to come
in with that mindset i already had a
plan in place
you did oh yeah of course i said i was
not going to go to the comedy store
for months and that he would have to
drive to long beach to see me and i was
not going to enter his world
at all and did did you go to the store
because i don't i don't i
i go i literally never i'm never there
and also in the beginning i went maybe
tom six months later i hooked it up baby
yeah baby i hooked he did he didn't
right
bad i write his coattails hard now i do
and now i can say
no but in the beginning listen listen
okay i could date a girl
right and you know i you know you can ex
access
me is that the right word yeah you're
excessive i'm accessible
right yeah but the thing is is you have
to have the
talent and the and the know-how and the
drive to do it
right and kalila's the perfect example
she
you know i mean she has the ability like
yeah you know we
just busted his balls a little bit no
but you also developed into
like a legit podcast talent you know
what i mean yeah yeah but you're
actually
you you probably started this feeling
like what do i do
or can i but like now you're you're
right like you're in
you're you're part of yeah yeah i've
even dated comedians that wouldn't be
able to do
what you do definitely you understand
what i'm saying so what i'm saying is is
that
dude there are high level comedians who
suck at this
this is a different skill set highly
different skill set yeah high high high
level comics
and that's why annie and esther they're
the ones that came to you
both zoomed you right or whatever that
was and
said can you please do a podcast with us
right i mean
you don't get that they're two credible
female comedians so it's like
you definitely um took this ball and you
ran with it
i did so you did hook me up yeah i did
it in a weird way and i i don't feel
that
to be gross wait you have to [ __ ] this
to go
that's the trade-off now why
you said if if if you weren't with bobby
if god forbid
a [ __ ] safe was dropped on his neck
when he was sleeping
if god for and you're like i would run
from this comedy world but
why why would you run from the from the
comedy world i think it just
feels like besides like the few good
apples that i've met
um and i'm just gonna be fully
transparent
here i don't find there's a whole lot of
people with integrity in this business
and i find them to be really slimy and
snaky and
once they have like it's almost like
everyone's sort of got the poison in
them and they don't even
there's a lack of awareness that they
all have the poison in them
and they all kind of like fight each
other and they they're jealous of each
other and everyone's like scrapping
it's just a world that like i'm barely
tolerating because my
the love of my life is in it yeah but i
try to keep as far away as possible like
i don't
like i said something last night that
made you go i don't like to listen to
his like hollywood like
something last night that really
triggered her and goes why do you even
get why right do you ever i just don't
give a [ __ ] about like
celebrity i don't give a [ __ ] about that
i don't care about these people do you
have because now because you're not
you might experience this more i i just
experienced it recently
where you ever like you go a long period
of time
only associating with like comics and
people in our world
and then like for whatever whatever
circumstances either you travel or or
you're introduced to your befriend
people that are not
and you kind of go like oh i forgot that
i'm in this like
niche world all the time